do you do you play cards you gamble no I
do denilla fortune slot machine alright
well hopefully you know at least like an
old lady the ACE the Aces are obviously
a good good card yeah as you know so I'm
gonna grab the Aces like this okay ready
one two three
I'm sorry this is just come out like
that
but tell you what um you know we're not
gonna I don't use Asians okay why there
it was just too easy no it's not that
it's not that it's just it's too clichéd
everyone thinks about the Aces yeah tell
you what not just these okay focus on
the back design as well til I will get
rid of the Aces so Kelley hand out like
this uh-huh okay great okay you're gonna
hold on to the Aces for the dry hands
I'm sorry make sure I don't go anywhere
near those okay keep it really close and
tight now max I'm gonna use you for a
big fan by the way all the parts very
different do you have a thought of card
in your head you had one sure all these
cards yes can you because I have no idea
these guys there's no one in the house
no so just go ahead and say out the card
what was the card that you're thinking
three of diamonds three times okay all
right well nothing's happened yet
I'm just saying okay alright watch watch
the seven okay okay you'll actually see
this happen you'll see me actually take
out the three diamonds inside the middle
of the deck and place it right over here
I just look like but that's that's not
the crazy part the crazy part is I
cannot just make one card
okay watch I cannot just make one card
I'll make every see just have you were
seeing every single car
every single car turning to the three
diamonds poit
Kelly you should feel those aces slowly
melting together into a single card and
you rub it it's a single card right now
max three diamonds right I know what you
guys are thinking I know you guys are
thinking you're thinking outpatients see
now all the cards are the same right and
before they were all different when I
first started right what I'm thinking
yeah yeah because okay but that's that's
not the case you see even though it's
all the same on the face there's still
very very different on the backs every
single card in Las Vegas different on
the back and now that these cards are
different right tell me what Kelly just
say stop as I do this okay good
right there okay guy over there in the
back I'm gonna just say the random
hotels okay the Rio Golden Nugget MGM
Grand Caesars Palace Excalibur good 6 a
1
MGM okay great right we'll grab the MGM
Grand
watch watch the MGM I can take the
actual hotel
Kelly I didn't go anywhere near that
card today oh I don't think so lightly
got just a little bit they could tear
the card right in the middle this time
it's just gently Terry I don't know
midway through look like they're tearing
an envelope yeah you see one card yeah
I'll do it I'll help you careful this
it's a delicate card oh my god oh my god
wait what why looks like the MGM Grand
to me I think let me just see my mind is
blown dude
I don't even know what to do does he
magically get a room there I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this